j'aimerais vous poser chacun une
question et vous aussi d'ailleurs on
pouvait poser des questions une question
que vous disiez chacun un petit mot sur
julien voilà parce que c'est vrai que ce
soit c'est sa dernière et moi je vous
dirais également un beau parce que voilà
j'ai plein de choses à lui dire à juju
et et on va commencer par part vous
jean-luc questions ou d'abord un gros
mot à peu près la question un petit mot
dans c'était un plaisir de partager
j'avais déjà été invité dans l'émission
de julien courbet j'avais vraiment
accroché je les ai découverts autrement
et j'ai beaucoup de respect pour lui
parce qu'il a il avait déjà une grosse
carrière avant d'arriver il a fait
preuve pendant ces quatre ans d'humilité
comme j'ai rarement vu parce qu'en plus
ce même là c'est il anime c'est que la
télé qui a fait un carton toute l'année
quand il vient dans l'émission il
redevient un chroniqueur il reste à sa
place et s'est prêté au jeu franchement
respect et j'étais content de partager
la route
merci bonjour l'image à la question là
justement c'était un carton c'est que la
télé mais honnêtement quand la proposer
parce que je crois que ça s'est fait
vite c'est que la télé leur voiture
voilà et est ce que tu t'es dit que
c'était un cadeau empoisonné au tout
départ en voiture julien quand je tape
et ouais j'ai revenez j'étais seule avec
mon chien je revenais du cap ferret moi
j'étais parti pour faire les vendredis à
ta place et on m'a appelé et m'a dit il
ya plus de vendredi monsieur arrêté
jeudi a plus rien donc normal ici et une
quotidienne qui devrait démarrer bientôt
et on ne sait pas encore ce qu'on va
mettre dehors mais on va bien trouver et
on a réfléchi très rapidement avec siri
non j'ai senti qu'au départ voilà ça
allait se faire vite mais pas que
c'était un cadeau empoisonné chalet qu'à
voir ce beau studio ch avec elle et à
voir les équipes d'âge et zorro
nettement g sinon je l'aurais pas fait
j'allais pas prendre le risque d'aller
au casse pipe je savais qu'il y aurait
un petit peu de tâtonnements mais
j'étais pas du tout inquiet quand il a
commencé à me dire qu'ils viendraient
dans l'émission là dessus non plus
j'avais envie à barvaux tout cas faire
en ville très grosse caisse et du
gilbert et julien courbet toutes ces
années cinq ans on m'avait beaucoup déçu
mais néanmoins je ne suis pas rancunier
si jamais vous échouez si jamais ce qui
est possible voire probable
je vous accueillerai ici à bras ouverts
merci
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'échoue je tuerai quelques questions
oui vous avez cyril comme producteur et
comment il est cyril comme producteur
très bien il m'a non non pas de langue
de bois il est j'étais dire pas de
langue de bois parce qu'il m'a vraiment
foutu la payer 2 3 fois cette année des
choses qui lui ont pas plu dans
l'émission voilà aime la vie et il se
trouve je dois le dire en bleu mans que
ce qu'il m'a demandé de changer à payer
dès le lendemain mais il me laisse
tranquille et l'interview que quand il
sent que ça va pas mais vraiment et je
tiens à le dire aussi parce que ça m'a
beaucoup étaient dit ça ne m'a jamais
posé de problème au contraire
là je suis arrivé pour une fois j'arrive
et je n'avais qu'à animer et à m'asseoir
y avait derrière une équipe d'âge au zoo
qui préparaient tous donc j'ai mis mon
petit grain de sel
mais ça a été un bonheur de ne plus
avoir à dire et la lumière etc
comment on fait quand on est producteur
et j'ai vraiment pris mon pied a rentré
d'europe dans ses pantoufles qui sont
compliqués en filet mais voilà ça a été
super merci rien jean michel maire oui
je la tue tortue a certainement pas mais
il ya de nombreuses années on s'est vus
on se crée un soir dans ta boîte de prod
parce qu'on devait annoncer le lendemain
dans le figaro ton départ de tf1 pour
france 2 tf1 l'apprenez langmann en
filières où c'est fou ça ici pour jouer
ou leurs journalistes
oui je vois son départ de ce soit dans
son bureau dans sa boite de prod en fait
il était le seul à le savoir
enfin la prenait s'étire au travail au
figaro et les pop up désert là
maintenant je vois son départ de céline
pour m6 donc j'aime bien voir ton trajet
comme ça et voilà il est apprécié
énormément je pense que tu le sais parce
que je trouve drôle intelligent sexy
surtout humain ce qui paraît qu'on peut
être pour la plupart des gens il m'a
laissé une qualité qui la sarthe et vise
donc pour être un grand seigneur est le
temps
et question que le bâton des victimes a
regretté
est ce qu'elle décrit l'onu car tu vas
regretter qu'ils tuent a regretté le
plus et qui tu vas être content quitter
comme chroniqueur comme il faut donner
des noms oui mais ordonnée bien
évidemment encore une fois j'insiste sur
le fait que quand on dit famille c'est
vraiment pas galvauder voilà je crois
qu'ils en groupe et alors dont on va
dire que ce que je vais regretter en
remercie
chez les garçons on va dire qu'il y en a
deux c'est jean luc et toi parce que
vous êtes les deux qui me font le plus
rire jean luc et à sniper qui est une
finale
et toi je trouve que tu t'es révélé et
honnêtement si aujourd'hui je devais
écrire une émission en choisissant des
profils de chroniqueurs je crois que tu
es honnêtement le meilleur lui ces voix
là c'est un comédien c'est la loire mais
tout est vraiment le meilleur
chroniqueur du côté du double il s'est
révélé ces deux dernières années il
s'est révélé ses yeux chroniqueurs c'est
vrai que c'est l'équipe mais je voudrais
dire deux mots sont avec eux
j'ai connu tout petit en fait un sévère
les années 90 quand on rentrait chez
louvain games et où les galettes ont été
enfermés dans un bureau pour écrire des
sketches pour remonter le paquebot dans
les soirées à wayne va pas remonter on
écrivait des sketches et des gags pour
jean pierre foucault s'est elle a
commencé l'année et a pas changé c'est
vrai qu'il a pas changé le dinar
géraldine alors julien moi j'ai la
chance de côtoyer depuis deux ans c'est
un collègue attentionné extrêmement bon
camarade sincère touchant très très
franc tu as une grosse expertise et
expérience aussi donc moi tout ce que je
te dis c'est un énorme un énorme merde
pour pour la suite tu étais donc le
joker de cyril hanouna pendant quatre
ans mais je vais savoir comment tu avais
vécu position de joker j'étais au départ
tétanisés mais vraiment tétanisés et
jusqu'à deux jours avant je me suis
demandé si j'allais pas lui dire je vais
pas le faire parce que voilà enfin on va
pas se mentir c'est compliqué de dire ça
parce qu'il est là mais voilà c'était à
nous nous parlait que de lui l'animateur
numéro un le talk-show numéro on te dira
moment donné tu va le remplacer donc je
savais qu'il y allait avoir une période
de transition où j'allais en prendre
plein la gueule parce que c'est normal
c'était à la fois une façon de me dire
allez 7 remets en cause c'est te donner
un coup de boost etc mais j'étais
tétanisée et encore une fois là où il a
été très très cool c'est qu'il m'a voilà
il m'a dit ne tombe pas dans tel piège
tel piège et très vite essayé de trouver
mes mains et il ya deux moments forts
dans ma carrière c'est sans aucun doute
pendant 20 ans je ne peux pas nier que
cette émission a changé ma vie et le
deuxième moment fort
cc touche pas à mon poste est encore
plus peut-être que c'est que de la télé
parce que je les fais cette année j'ai
adoré mais c'est c'est cette émission
canton l'animé le jeudi soir jusqu'à une
heure du matin
enfin pour ceux qui sont venus ça
restera mais plus grands moments de
bonheur je ne savais pas mais je le dis
honnêtement que je pourrai autant rire
sur un plateau ça reste quand même un
boulot de la tension est là mais je me
rappelle à une heure du matin je
rentrais chez moi ma famille et ça s'est
bien passé vie mais
avoir comme je me suis la reo coria
voilà donc merci s'irrite pour savoir
quatremer qui m'ont aidé
je viens pour de grands parce que parce
que je vais te dire je ce métier
malheureusement est maintenant m'a
apporté beaucoup beaucoup de déception
dans les rencontres en tout cas parce
qu'évidemment je rêvais d'être animateur
tout ça est de les rencontrer et on va
dire que 8 fois sur 10 je suis tombé sur
des gens que je citerai pas c'est pas le
but de ce soir mais souvent un plein des
gautherets gentil à l'antenne non
et en vrai pas très gentil bref ces
raids font rarement rencontré 6 2 on est
souvent déçu et et parmi les animateurs
les plus humains que j'ai rencontrés ils
tiennent sur une main je pense et tu en
fais partie à chaque fois que te
demander rendez-vous qu'on a déjeuné
ensemble considère beaucoup de choses
que tu as gardé pour toi et tout ça bref
donc c'est vrai que c'est mieux
sincèrement parce que je t'aime vraiment
beaucoup monsieur ne peut pas dire qu'on
est amis puis kg une vraie vraie
sympathie pour toi donc je fais vraiment
vraiment le meilleur
j'aurais aimé que tu restes parce que
j'aurai presque aimé aussi qu'on puisse
peut-être faire des choses d'année
prochaine
travailler avec toi j'aurais beaucoup
aimé même encore l'autre jour je te
demande un rendez-vous pour justin
conseil de prod tu m'a reçu dans son
bureau et avait que deux minutes bref je
te dis tu fait vraiment partie des gens
qui tiennent sur une main dans ce métier
voilà pour le ce que tu veux dire
il sera moins émouvante pour l'un pour
la question en revanche voilà il a été
dit beaucoup beaucoup de choses sur
pleins pleins de sites sur ce que tu vas
faire l'année prochaine
j'imagine qu'il ya beaucoup de bêtises
et peut-être du vrai et alors que tu
peux nous en dire un petit peu plus et
si tu dois le dire quelque part est ce
que ce serait pas ici alors je rêverais
de vous dire je sais voilà il ya des
choses qui sont encore floues il ya des
choses précises mais je ne peux pas
parce que c'est la volonté je vais faire
respecter sa de la chaîne 2 de choisir
le tempo le bon moment pour dire ce que
je vais faire par contre je peux vous
dire ce que je ne vais pas faire et ce
qui a été dit qui a beaucoup énervé
gilles sur cette émission absolument 1
j'ai une bonne nouvelle prothèse ça ne
sera pas du tout ça tant mieux
cette commission n'existe pas d'accord
on ne m'en a jamais parlé est juste une
petite parenthèse pour une raison très
simple c'est que ces histoires de
conciliation cd conciliation officielle
et seul un avocat alors de faire une
conciliation officielle où un animateur
ne peut pas le faire donc y aura
d'autres choses je pense que vous allez
savoir très très vite
mais voilà je laisse le soin au
président taverne où je n'ai pas envie
de me fâcher avec lui avons monde donc
je vais lui laisser le soin de vous l'aï
dit tu sais que ta cueillir les bras
ouverts qui lui revient
singh a dit moi je n'ai pas beaucoup
connu je lis ici parce que je suis pas
là depuis longtemps mais la marque
julien courbet en tout cas c'est une
marque on connaît depuis longtemps
qu'ils respectaient apprécié qui devrait
mark et moi ce que j'ai apprécié un peu
moi s'il fallait te définir
d'une certaine façon ça serait vraiment
faire du sérieux sans se prendre au
sérieux
je pense que ça te convient parfaitement
bien faire vraiment sanomat c'est quand
je suis venu je peux vous le dire aussi
beaucoup m'ont m'ont critiqué
beaucoup m'ont dit c'est une grave
erreur tu ne vas quand même pas les te
mettre autour de la table de cyril
hanouna t julien courbet alors ça déjà
je l'aurais dit eh oui le problème je
vois très bien voilà son plat ni 20 voix
apparaît un jour tous ces bien pensants
qui m'avait vu c'est vrai faire sans
aucun doute pendant 20 ans ont vu arrivé
déguisé en shakira est plus bien placé
la fois d'après enchaîne mais là
vraiment on m'a dit mais tu te rends
compte comme tu es tombé bas c'est fini
tu es morte est devenu ben non non parce
que quand c'est fait avec sincérité
il n'y a aucun problème à sa foi que les
gens ils ont envie de s'amuser je ne
vois pas pourquoi et au nom de quoi au
cv l'image
moi j'ai appris à la halla halla
connaître à l'utiliser l'image de ce
qu'ils disent attention c'est pour mon
image
ok il faut faire gaffe peut-être mais là
quand on est dans un contexte et qu'on
le fait sincèrement il ya aucun problème
d'image absolument aucun et je les fais
je me suis éclaté j'ai même peur de vous
dire que peut-être que je vais faire des
choses un peu plus sérieuses mais qu'à
un moment donné ça va me manquer de pas
arriver comme ça déguisée at accueillera
à bras ouverts
je les fais je les fais sincèrement et
je crois que cyril peut le reconnaître
quand je le faisais je le faisais
vraiment c'est le show il est à fond ils
adorent ils veulent s'amuser on est là
on est payé pour ça pour donner le
maximum et on ne réfléchit pas et puis
alors attend entre nous en coulisses
quand on se voit dans le couloir lui
nous à se regarder c'est celle plus
drôle c'est quand aux é internationaux
que tu as l'air con et toi tu t'es vue
et on s'éclate comme dans une colo quoi
et ça c'est des moments que je
n'oublierai jamais vous avez une
question que sinon oui même deux la
plénière s'il fallait que tu déjeunes
avec une personne une seule de tous les
chroniqueurs il y en a beaucoup qui ça
serait à bessat serait géraldine parce
que vraiment là j'aurais pas
l'impression de perdre mon temps et je
vous remercie
dans les littératures on parlait pas à
s'en saisir un mot si cette question
rapidement justement avec tout ce
parcours rtl tf1 france 2 ou est-ce que
tu as eu la plus de le plus de liberté
le plus bien plus grande marge de
manoeuvre c'est pourquoi et en quoi ici
ici moi j'ai connu la télé 2 des années
90 sur tf1 ou quand on faisait à eux le
simple fait de faire eu un mot de
travers site un politique il fallait
tout couper ici je suis désolé mais à
aucun moment que ce soit sur le plateau
de touche pas à mon poste c'est encore
plus où on parle un peu d'actu sur le
plateau de c que de la télé on ne m'a
empêché de dire quoi que ce soit on
demande j'ai c'est à dire des choses
justes a pas dire n'importe quoi et c8
et je le dis je les dis je crois dans
une interview récemment l'espace de
liberté je crois à la télé le plus grand
et il est une illusion l'espace et fait
tous autant que vous êtes en sorte que
ça reste comme ça parce qu'on a besoin
d'une chaîne il peut se passer n'importe
quoi critique pour vocation de passer
n'importe quoi ce truc qu'il faut
vraiment fort et d arte geie sa merci il
nous reste six à m isabelle ben moi
julien on se suit quasiment depuis 30
ans à la russie d'accueillir mots
couverts mais n'a jamais voulu que ce
n'était pas assez écarté
[Rires]
hier
j'adore julien parce que comme avec
cyril comme avec jean-luc même quand ils
disent rien il se passe toujours quelque
chose une partie son mix entre des fois
il se passe toujours quelque chose et
c'est formidable
moi j'ai la chance que l'on se retrouve
à tous les maux tous les jours on se
parle tous les jours par antenne
interposés il va me manquer même si elle
c'est bizarre parce qu'on se voie eh ben
il va quand même le monde sait que je
suis ici mais déjà parce qu on se
soutenait groupe août et une bonne
guerre parce qu'on était là remettait
ensemble et donc ma question c'est
justement quand on voit ce que pour et
par cyril est ce que papa un chantre
sentiment d'inachevé un tout petit peu
de fuites
en partant de là sachant qu'il avait
encore des choses à faire et sachant que
m6 de toute façon tous regardés vu le
bon boulot que tu fais d'inachevé
peut-être effectivement je crois que l'
aventure c'est que de la télé nommé qu'à
ses balbutiements et je prends le pari
ici que cette émission va monter à 600
et 700 régulièrement avec valérie bénaïm
parce que voilà une petite connaissance
des concepts depuis le temps que je le
fais il ya un truc
cette émission il ya un truc des petits
réglages encore à faire qu'il fera avec
valérie mais une quotidienne ça
s'installe dans le temps regardez les
laisser les recours sur battu au bout de
7 8 heures donc elle est partie donc
voilà maintenant non je fuis pas j'ai
donné tout ce que je pouvais ici il ya
un challenge qui arrive qui est
intéressant pour moi j'y vais mais juste
une parenthèse pour vos risa j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure des garçons et si tu
m'avais demandé que les mains
chroniqueuse préféré isa le vent le
jeudi soir quand on enregistrait jusqu'à
une heure du matin après le porter à 3
heures sur rtl pour bosser tout elle a
toujours été là comme un pilier des fois
je me disais je suis fatigué mais je
viens pour toi et je m'appuyais sur elle
et quand je voyais que j'ai démarré le
touche pas à mon poste et qui avait
isaac était là je vais des rations je
sais que la voilà il peut rien m'arriver
et voilà ce titre là merci
[Applaudissements]
pas mal quand j la bataille pour le bol
avant lui jean louis d'avoir le mot de
bagarre parce que c'est vrai que et
qu'elle il ya kenny qui avait préparé
une fiche en plus grands maux qui minent
et ça on l'avait créé à travers quoi ton
dépend de limagrain annonce gérer un
formateur attend à préparer non mais si
j'ai une question parents travaillent
alors julien je voulais dire que moi je
me suis éclatée avec toi surtout en le
stylisme je sais ce que c'est de la
rigolade rigole bien ensemble en plus on
a partagé une danse de fou on croit que
c'est vraiment ça c'était beau et après
j'ai une petite question j'aurais voulu
savoir si l'argent avait joué un rôle
majeur
non il a joué un rôle majeur que
quelques refus rester wind arts et le
nom mais alors que je vois si c'était
une question d'argent je pense que je
serais resté je peux dire la vérité
brute est franchement de ce que je sais
sachez que julien va vraiment on peut
lire c'est du simple au double en faveur
de ces huit produire il va produire
c'est du simple au double en faveur de
ces huit c'est pas une 15e en production
je vous le dis j'ai les infos mais je
voulais vraiment julien n'est pas du
tout parti pour l'argent puisque il sera
il gagnera deux fois mois sur m6 que ce
qu'il aurait gagné sur ces 8 et julien
je crois que ça peut me confirmer vosges
vosges et pas calculer mais enfin moi
c'est en tout cas c'est pas pour ça